[Music] There Are
Two Main Types of Ratios To Understand The
Types Look At The Pond Which
Has Two Kinds Of Fish The Red Fish And The
Blue Fish There Are 14 Fish In
Total 10 Red Ones And Four Blue
Ones Let's Write It Down Here 10  Red fish
and four blue
fish let us find one ratio first the ratio
of the red fish to the blue fish since there are
10 red fish and four blue fish the ratio will be
10/4 2 ta 5 gives us 10 and 2 ta 2 gives
As 4 Hence this
ratio in the lowest terms is
5/2 The ratio can also be written As
5:2 What is the ratio of the blue fish to the
red fish It is 4/1 4 blue fish and 10 red
fish this can be  Reduce to 2/5 and the ratio
is written as
2:5 Look at the ratio carefully when comparing
a part to a part What kind of ratio is called
part to part ratio than what is
called the other kind of
ratio  R called part to whole ratio an example would be
the ratio of the number of red
fish to all the fish in the pond the number of red
fish is 10 and the total number of fish is 14 hence it
equals 10 by 14 the ratio in
lowest  The form can be written as
5/7 and the ratio is written as
5:7 Similarly the ratio of the blue fish to all
fish is
4/1 which gives us
2/7 The ratio is
2:7 So in these examples we compared a
Part to the whole Red to all and blue to all
In the part to the whole We
compared red to blue and blue to all
[Music]
Red